brought to you by Dark Souls 3 pre-order
now to receive a free upgrade to the day
one edition on this week sponsored
episode we are talking the hardest
bosses in the soul series now there are
heaps to choose from and how hard you
found each of them probably depends on
your character build and your skill
level at the time of fighting them that
said here are 6 of the worst at number 6
we've got the ruined sentinels from Dark
Souls 2 these armor guys get you with
massive hall birds they have jumping
attacks and a spinning attack which is
way too fast to outrun so you'll need to
learn to block it while each sentinels
recovery time after their attacks can
give you a second to get in a hit of
your own you will need to be wary of the
other two who appear to be pretty
determined to connect their blades to
your face malice is one of the hardest
bosses in Dark Souls although you may
not have faced up against him since he's
only in the artorias of the abyss DLC
Manas is the father of the abyss and he
looks exactly as ominous as that sounds
he's insanely quick and aggressive and
has a ton of different moves which can
be very hard to predict luckily for you
you can summon SIF they're not so little
wolf to give you a hand
Manas has a bunch of combos where he
unleashes multiple hits as part of the
same route to take you to eighty bitty
pieces you want to commit to either
blocking with your shield or brawling
out of the way and using the silver
pendant will help fend off his hugely
damaging and spammy dark magic attacks
if you play it all the way through demon
souls chances are you remember fighting
old king allant because he's a right
pain he charges super-powerful sweeping
attacks that launch him across the room
and appear to home to your gullet
so good luck getting out of the way he
also has a fierce slice attack and three
hit combo blocking his mighty swings is
essential and the fight is a balancing
act between trying to avoid his waves of
attacks and getting your own Ian while
he's charging up the next blow
unfortunately he's super magic resistant
and his signature move is capable of
pulling down your soul level and remove
that last step point you gain a lot of
people claim that flame Locker is the
bane of their souls series experience
given either monstrous beasts engulfed
in flame you can probably understand why
Stern Fang tunnel and Demon Souls is
already no walk in the park but trapped
at the end of it is this hulking and
super cranky boss not only will flame
look and smack you in the face with this
fiery pause he slammed down massive
fireball attacks that are extremely hard
to avoid he's very quick and has no
qualms about charging after you
relentlessly before launching an attack
to ensure you have maximum difficulty
getting out of the blast radius luckily
for you he's pretty weak to magic just
so long as you don't use fire magic
which you wouldn't because the guy is
literally 99% fire I'm sure you're
expecting this one so I'm going to roll
through it quickly
giant player on screen and executioner
Smaug are the dynamic duo who guard the
princess of sunlight in dark souls and
their bloody ruff to kill usually you
can adapt your build and attack style to
the foe you're facing but that becomes
way harder when you need to deal with
one speedy spear wielding agile bastard
and an enormous lumbering dude with a
giant hammer at the same time make sure
you don't damage both bosses at once
since the second surviving guy will
absorb his dead power and regenerate to
full health when you do manage to kill
one and last on our list is fume light
from duxelle to few Knight is a massive
armored soldier wielding two giant
blades it's fortunate that there's a
bonfire right beside the battle area
because you're probably going to be
running back in after your untimely
death a lot black Manas fume Knight has
a ton of different moves which are very
difficult to predict they include a 360
degree sword swing and an attack that
launches a series of swirling fireballs
at you
not to mention that once you get him
down to half health I'll set his sword
of flame as the gamer who played the
very run you're watching wrote the key
to this battle is dodging and if you
aren't great at dodging you will be by
the time you eventually beat this guy
obviously there are loads of great souls
bosses that I haven't had
to mention in this video so be sure to
drop me your favorites and your pics
with toughest boss battles in the
comments I will catch you again next
week